i can't believe i get to congratulate
you oh no thank you so much it is
excellent where tennis mad down in
australia as you know but this movie is
about so much more isn't it
why are people just loving it you know
it's um
well i wish i knew for sure because i
would do it all the time so there's a
there's an x factor that happens you
know uh you know this is this is the
critic's choice so just so the critics
know this is what i tried to do every
time
i'm not trying to do it the other way
but it's
it's just magic you know a whole lot of
things
came together
for for this film
zach's screenplay
was ridiculous from from
page one
the williams family was was supportive
so they sat on on every scene and every
moment and made themselves available to
to the actors to really capture the
authenticity just
you know ray was the the perfect uh
director anjanu you know just what we
were able to create scene by scene
sanaya and demi and just you know um
the the the magic happened with this one
you're pretty good yourself in it thank
you thank you thank you any chance
you're coming by to visit us in
australia anytime soon i would love to i
was i was thinking about uh coming a
couple of weeks ago i have a friend that
that lives there i was going to come
train i love the uh what is that the
bronte to bandai
the no no i i run sorry i run i walk
here okay i mean i'm an action hero you
know sorry
no but i love training there so i'll
probably be there in the next couple
months we'd like to see you thank you
thanks will congrats thank you
hey rachel stern from entertainment
tonight hello first of all
congratulations thank you so much you've
been so emotional this awards yes and
tonight you know you what you think
i was feeling song
you acknowledged aunt you know you
acknowledged serena you acknowledged
how emotional has it been you know
acknowledging this what this woman and
winning
award after award after war you know
you're taking them all will no thank you
thank you you know it is um
you know so i've i've played real life
characters a couple times and it it
holds an extra burden
because when i play someone everyone's
going to assume that that's the real
story and that's how it was
you know so
there there's a there's a an awful you
know couple of weeks when the movie's
finished and now you know the family is
going to going to start to see it
and there's an emotional release
when people feel honored when you tell
a true story and venus and serena and
their entire family
watched the film and they were a mess
and they were crying and talking about
scenes and things um
and you know so there's a bit of an
emotional release for that um
you know and then just all of that the
the actors and you know sanaya and demi
and and anjanu i just um
you know this this is the guy i want to
be in this business you know introducing
and and shielding
actors coming into
uh this world you know so i just i love
it i just uh this is a this is a high
point in my career
and lastly i have to ask oh just real
quick you joked about
best actors should get more time so is
there anything else you want to say you
have oh yeah
no you know i i felt like i got it all
out i definitely felt like i got it out
um
you know there there's a
uh there's a there's a power to their
story
um
that you know i would encourage people
to even still look some of the things
that this family had to survive you know
uh one of the things we did that didn't
make it into
the film their sister
uh their sister tunde was was murdered
you know
and you know their sister was murdered
and you know it was two and a half weeks
later they had to play
a tournament you know and it was just
what this family had to survive to do
what they did is is you know spectacular
you know yes
any time for one one yes one more
run back right that's that's stunning
oh like brown questions are better than
every other color question
um what is something about the williams
sisters that maybe you knew before that
you learned more about after like did
your perception of them change at all
and what's something that we wouldn't
know about them you know one of the one
of the major things
was the image that we all saw was an
overbearing father pushing
his kids to succeed and we felt like we
knew that story and when i sat with
venus and serena they were like it was
it was completely the other way that
venus called it the jedi mind trick that
somehow he had tricked them into
believing that they had to force him to
let them play tennis their punishment
was that they weren't allowed to play
tennis and he had created a relationship
with them where it was their dream that
he was helping them with
and you know it was funny watching them
and venus said i have no idea how he did
that but you know serena talked about
being on punishment one time and she
took rubber bands and a sock and made it
in and she was hitting the rubber bands
and the sock up against the wall which
is how bad she wanted to play tennis and
with that they never felt like they were
getting pushed by their their parents
right so that was one of the the major
um you know
parenting savant techniques
you